un nuevo episodio de violencia en la
ciudad vieja de jerusalén un atacante
palestino mató a una persona e hirió
otras cuatro dos de ellos policías
después fue reducido por las fuerzas de
seguridad en una rápida respuesta en una
zona altamente controlada ocupa 35 la
respuesta a los policías del distrito de
jerusalén fue rápida en 32 segundos
reaccionaron desde numerosas direcciones
y mataron al terrorista
el atacante vestía como un ultraortodoxo
judío portaba una carlo una arma
automática de fabricación casera y
pertenecía al brazo político de hamás un
portavoz del grupo lo calificó de
operación heroica la resistencia de
nuestro pueblo seguirá siendo legítima
por todos los medios y herramientas
contra la ocupante sionista hasta que se
logren nuestros objetivos y la ocupación
sea expulsada de nuestros lugares
sagrados y de todas nuestras tierras
el primer ministro israelí y naftalí
bennett reaccionó saludando a la
intención del gobierno británico de
proscribir el ala política del grupo que
gobierna en la franja de gaza
acaso hasta ahora sólo se ha definido
como tal el brazo militar ahora los
miembros del ala política estarán
expuestos a las mismas sanciones esto
refleja una comprensión bienvenida que
espero se extienda a toda europa sobre
cómo funcionan las organizaciones
terroristas le dejo la europa
este es el segundo ataque en los últimos
cuatro días el miércoles un adolescente
murió por disparos de la policía
fronteriza tras apuñalar a dos agentes
[Música]
los enfrentamientos son habituales al
aqsa conocido como santuario noble para
los palestinos es un lugar sagrado para
los judíos es el monte del templo
también venerado